let's talk about this super bowl
halftime show performance
so the weekend took to the stage and a
very different stage that was actually
built at one end of the field
this meant that there weren't like
hundreds of workers running out on the
field at the beginning of halftime
to assemble a stage yes it was just at
one end of the field he fit all his hits
and it was 13 minutes set and as you
said there were no special guests
just him and a whole lot of dancers
yeah so lots of celebrities reacted to
the show and even the canadian prime
minister justin trudeau tweeted
congratulations on rocking the world's
biggest stage the weekend you're
certainly earned it
hope you had uh heard from all the
cheers from back home
uh diane warwick also said well done the
weekend
love the set and pyros you looked and
sounded great a big hug and loud
applause and keith urban wrote damn the
weeknd love the entire field being the
stage
now fellow torontonian drake posted on
instagram that he was watching
and on his own story timothy chalamet
just yelled legend once it was over
[Applause]
big sixer
exo
[Applause]
the national football league
[Music]
and then yeah so now for his own
celebration afterwards
we can enjoy the cigar when it was all
said and done
so if we have that uh that b-roll adam
of him uh with this guy there he is
having joined a cigar like a golf cart
backstage
and here's what he had to say in the
interview with the nfl network before he
took to the stage and how he put his own
money into the show
what does seven million dollars buy you
at raymond james stadium
well honestly it was it was tough to to
bring the vision to life
with what we had at the time you know we
really wanted to be safe
we really thought about the the players
and and the workers so we
built the stage within the actual
stadium we'll still be using the field
and other parts as well too but whatever
it takes you know
going through this process what's been
the toughest part for you figuring out
how to perform
to potentially an empty stadium
potentially 20
000 we didn't really know what we were
doing we just knew that
we'd have to be creative and figure it
out and i think you know roc nation
made the right choice in in picking me
to
bring something special to to a
situation like this yeah jeff says loved
it he did pretty well with what he had
to work with jennifer says i love the
weekend he did amazing
guys just says at least he was better
than five samantha's mom was good he was
a lot better than last year
so samantha thinks she was better than
j.lo and shakira what did you think jim
i'm still okay
i have to admit i'm still dying over the
maroon 5 because
trust me i'm still recovering from that
um
this is the truth okay i i this is the
most weekend i've ever watched in my
life
um so i have to be honest it was it was
good
um i had a few concerns i i wish you
kind of
you know paid a little homage to the
scarborough town center and that
architecture
i was looking around i'm like where's
scarborough town center where's the cn
tower
um but to me what i what was lacking for
me
was that audience interaction so in the
clip before
he did say that we weren't sure if we
were performing to an audience to 20 000
people or to an empty stadium
but obviously that day he knows that
there's people in the stadium
and it just felt like it was
disconnected like there wasn't any
crowd interaction to get his height and
to me it seemed more like an award show
performance
um and i was also worried about the
music because the weekend songs are like
baby making music so i wasn't sure how
he was going to bring this into this
family
event right room five
thank you i i think it was absolutely
brilliant this is a character that he
has been creating for a year we saw him
i think it was in august and mtv music
awards where we saw the bruises and then
again in november we saw the wrapping of
his face with the red suit
and this was an homage to everything
that he's been creating i think the song
uh savior tears where he actually has a
plastic surgery
so these were all the steps to the
conclusion yesterday and so
i dissected i watched it like 12 times
yesterday night to figure out what the
storyline was
and right from the beginning he's in
front of this choir and it's this
innocent moment of him trying to make it
in hollywood and then all of them on the
field like that's the first time seeing
all those characters that's him on the
field and breaking it down the fact that
you know there are all these collisions
and he's
he breaks down as a person and he goes
through this whole uh
this journey in his life and even when
he was with the blinded uh lights in
that room and what that that chaos was
in his life
i think it was absolutely amazing it was
the
the ending we needed to that character i
don't think he's ever gonna wear that
red suit again
but the best show i've ever seen was
bruno mars is my favorite
but the weekend killed it and canada was
celebrating yesterday night that was
such a highlight
especially after snl on saturday with
dan levy oh canada it was i thought it
was amazing
bridgette says we love the weekend they
did an amazing job jk says the weekend
should ask for a refund because those
seven million
were nowhere to be seen it was boring
i'm not really yeah like i didn't really
see
where he needed to spend his own money
like it didn't strike me as it was a
bigger
spectacle than other halftime shows i
don't know like was the fireworks did he
put money more into fireworks i don't
know where seven million dollars of his
own money
needed to go that didn't seem like that
much more respectful than we've seen in
in past years ronnie says i thought it
was awful um
pretty says he was amazing martin says i
appreciate the artist's
efforts and vision it was decent but i
did expect more i will say
i think it was cocky of him not to have
a special guest i think i know he was
saying beforehand
that it didn't fit his narrative i
didn't really see what this narrative
was that
i guess couldn't have been part of like
i mean everyone's had a special guest so
i do think it would have been nice to
have
someone just to bring a wow factor to it
like i love the weekend but i did think
it
it ends up being a halftime show that
i'm not going to remember
in a week it put on a level like justin
timberlake like it was decent
not like yeah i think of bruno mars i
think a beyonce i think a jlo i think of
shakira like those ones that really
stood out to me in the last few years
this one isn't going to be one that i
watch over and over again it was fine
but i do think it was a little like yeah
cocking them not to have a special guest
come and join him
like a maluma like maluma would have how
dare you say that come on
cocky this whole storyline was about him
and his his character everyone wanted to
know what this was all about this whole
thing he's been doing
that he's been keeping up the last year
i think it was great
and he's right if someone did come into
the storyline it doesn't work with the
narrative of the story so
i think that's the problem i think he
forgot to explain that whole thing
what this conclusion was to his
storyline so uh for me i
didn't even know there was a couldn't
have had somebody i know
i don't know this is the first time i'm
here like this
this was this has been developing this
has been developed now
the okay i'll give him i'll give him
some kudos
the whole mask thing i was like okay i
see what you did there corona
okay cool cool um but i was shook
the choir had me shook i was getting
like michael jackson thriller vibes
i was scared because i was more scared
than entertained
uh you know i think he did something
amazing during covent and what he was
trying to do and
the fact that he took over the whole
field was something that spectacular
we've never seen before
um i just think it's it should be more
celebrated than taken down because
what he did with the the timing of all
of this i
i mean i was even nervous the idea of
having so many people together during
covet but
a lot of those people were vaccinated in
the in the uh stadium but
um yeah the sound was off a little bit
but
yeah that was off the beginning yeah his
first song and then no i do think it
wasn't genius how they built that stage
at the end of the
one field didn't have to have workers on
field and then yeah when he did go on
the field
like you said jam they're all in masks
as part of the the bandage look
i thought that was really really
ingenious and there was an amazing
visual like having all those dancers
i don't know how many dancers literally
filling that entire hundred yard field
on i know how many i know how many
dancers
it was it was more dancers than casey
scored
oh
[Laughter]
i was there for the snacks i don't know
what was happening
but yeah i agree yeah yeah
so everyone so okay okay thumbs up or
thumbs down guys
well thumbs up for sure yeah thumbs up
but just like you know emoji
shrug emoji emoji okay
i was a proud canadian i was proud
canadian like that is big when you when
you okay all
freaky mask aside to go from
you know a scarborough kid performing at
dundas square to the super bowl that's
massive but from a creative standpoint
i'm shook weekend i'm i'm i'm shocked
yeah let me sad i'm so sad
he's sad okay all right
we love you weekend we all love you